commercial kitchens from our favorite
restaurants and fast food places produce
some of the toughest and thickest grease
if left uncleaned it can cause serious
damage to sewage systems health risks
from contaminated food and even kitchen
fires
here's how some of the greasiest parts
of restaurant kitchens are
professionally deep cleaned
Jay Lopez the owner of Kleenex walks us
through how his team cleans a
restaurant's kitchen exhaust system
which extracts the fumes from the
kitchen
today I'm going to be walking you
through how we clean the kitchen exhaust
system in the restaurant
the purpose of a kitchen exhaust system
is to extract the fumes from a kitchen
in a commercial setting in order to
remove grease you have to understand
Grease what holds the oil together is
the fat and once the first layer is up
it becomes a magnet and it attracts more
and more and more
everything is clean from top to bottom
you would start cleaning the fan first
we're using a high-end Degreaser and
with a little potassium hydroxide and
sodium hydroxide those two chemicals
combine create miracles in destroying
the fat into grease in our case we time
it somewhere between 10 to 15 minutes
once we see that the grease starts to
melt at that point we know we need to
apply hot water and remove it because
anything longer at that point is going
to start to destroy the metal
once the fan has been cleaned the next
step would be the dock that's the part
that connects the fan to the hood
this level is considered extreme that
was a fire waiting to happen
I would say this is about a year worth
of Grease it all depends on the volume
of cooking if this is a moderate cooking
this is about a Year's worth of Grease
that's a lot
the duck is clean in a few different
steps during this process we use a tool
made by Guardian this tool is known as
the easy magnetic duct scraper it has
magnets set into the tool and a razor
blade on each side
once it's cleansed to the dock it is
manually moved forward and backwards
until the grease is removed this lower
and backward method assures that the
grease buildup will be removed from both
sides
you'll go from the yellow color all the
way into the black when it's in the
Black Level that's an extreme level that
means that the system has not been
properly maintained
and these types of designs we'll use
duck Spinners and duck brushes duck
spinner is designed to self-rotate with
any protective cage and spray water at
high speed which this Lodge build up
from the metal dock
we use a combination of a foaming agent
and a Degreaser the foam is used as a
delivering agent and allows the
Degreaser to stay in contact with
degrees for a longer period the foam was
not used the Degreaser would drip off
the grease
The Next Step would be the put and the
filters
filters are your first line of defense
what the filters is doing is holding
back heat and is holding back most of
that grease when the filters no longer
can hold the grease and once that grease
starts getting heat and melting you have
the potential of that grease dropping
into your food and at that point it's a
health issue I've seen restaurants been
shut down by the health department for
not cleaning their Hood I've seen
restaurants been shut down by the fire
marshal for not maintaining their hoods
foreign
we take precaution in protecting the
area from contamination we use two
layers of plastic sheeting in order to
protect the appliances from coming in
contact with any chemical the second
layer of plastic sheeting is wrapped
around the hood and then a funnel is
created the funnel is used to drain the
chemical grease and water into the
plastic containers
the plastic sheeting also serves as a
protective barrier in preventing the
chemical from coming in contact with the
food preparation area
once we're completed and the plastic
sheeting is removed will conduct a fresh
water wipe down and recommend to the
client that they do the same prior to
preparing any food
according to NFPA 96 which is the agency
that regulates this industry the
frequency of cleanings depends on the
style of cooking you're conducting and
the frequency of cooking for example if
you cook with solid fuel solid fuel is
basically cooking with charcoal those
are 30-day mandatory cleanings because
they produce a lot more grease and the
ambers that come from the silent fuel
can ignite the grease if you're an
occasional cooking facility those would
be a year
Maurice Patterson who co-owns MMP
Environmental Solutions walks us through
how he cleans a grease trap in a
restaurant kitchen
today we will be cleaning a commercial
roof strap in a Mediterranean restaurant
the function of a grease trap is to
prevent any solids fats oil increases
from dishwasher or dishwashing sinks
from entering your piping system
so the cleaning process typically starts
with me inspecting it making sure it's
functional
typically you want to clean your grease
strap off every three months I would say
that it hasn't been the service most
likely close to a year then we unplug
the grease trap and we start to remove
all the components
from that step we will prepare them to
be cleaned but the pressure washer
so right here we're doing our pump out
we have the wand connected to the high
powered vacuum pump we'll use the wand
to pump out the entire grease trap so as
you can see there's a lot of greasing on
top of the grease trap and you can get a
glimpse of solids that have floated to
the top as well for Mediterranean
restaurants you're going to get a lot of
oils cheeses they're also going to get a
lot of rice the rice is usually the main
contents that sink to the bottom of the
grease trap that you're going to want to
pump out regularly I would describe it
as yellow grease so yellow grease is
typically grease that's used to make
fries or things like that
there's actually two different types of
Grease known in the industry you have
brown grease that's typical grease
that's scraped off from pots and pans
that have traveled down into your
dishwasher and your sink down to your
grease draft and then you also have
yellow grease you can actually sell it
certain places they may recycle that
grease and turn it into biofuel things
like that
it's considered Liquid Gold some
companies will actually pay them for it
so they're incentivized to make sure
that it's not going down the drain
here what I'm using is a putty knife I'm
scraping just old food waste that has
collected on there
organic wastage turns black over time
into oxidized and turns black it's a
health risk mainly because of any type
of overflows from your grease trap may
come in contact with food
we use a pressure washer to system make
sure we're getting all the residual
solids cleaned up
I'm using steel wool just to do a final
scrub down make sure I'm getting into
all the nooks and crannies all the tight
spaces
I do this right before we do a final
spray down with the pressure washer
so we dispose of the grease added water
solution control facility that will
accept the fast oil and grease and
there's not many places that do accept
it so it's limited but you know we
dispose of an environmentally
responsible way
foreign
goes on the drain with the dishwater
it's typically hot so grease or Oils
when they're hot they're liquefied when
they cool down they solidify in the
drain that may cause plugging which will
in turn cause backups overflows if it
negatively impacts your solar system
then they can incur fines they will have
to buy a new grease trap or pay Plumbing
fees to rectify the problems
Steve the owner of Superior clean walks
us through how he cleans a commercial
exhaust system
We Begin the cleaning process by
removing the kitchen Hood filters and
wrapping the exhaust Hood to ensure that
we properly contain all of the greasy
water
[Music]
we'll start at the upper duct work where
the grease accumulates the most the top
of the duct work here is where the
grease the smoke and the heat exits the
purpose of cleaning the upper ductwork
first is to ensure that we properly
flush the entire ductwork back into the
kitchen Hood
so our goal as a certified hood cleaning
company is to ensure that all accessible
areas of the hood and duct work are bare
metal meaning there is no grease left
over and there's no possibility of a
kitchen fire
so the way we start degreasing the
system is with a high foaming agent and
we can mix in sodium or potassium
hydroxide to strengthen up our mix
from there we will scrape down the
ductwork to ensure that all the thick
grease is removed before we come back
and hit it with high pressure steam
cleaning
so what you're seeing here in this fast
food establishment is the fatty grease
that are being pulled into the exhaust
system and it's very watery much
different than you'll see in Chinese
places or steakhouses that have more of
a carbonized grease
steakhouses are generally like built on
carbon Chinese places you have extremely
thick gooey grease we typically see with
Wok peanut oil it becomes a very rubbery
substance it's almost like a rubberized
Gorilla Glue it's extremely difficult to
clean and it requires a lot of scraping
degreasing
it moves down vertically to a horizontal
90 Bend and that's where the inline
exhaust fan sits
to the left of the system there are two
access panels which gives you the
accessibility to scrape degrees and
steam clean inside of the ductwork to
make sure that the system remains bare
metal and that leads you into the
kitchen where the exhaust hood is
exhaust fans are generally the dirtiest
part of the kitchen exhaust system due
to it being the last point of Passage
before it exes
we just finished off with steam cleaning
the upper duct work which flushes the
grease down through the inline exhaust
fan and now we're moving to the inner
blades
so what we're looking for when applying
the Degreaser on the exhaust fan blades
in the duct work is the foam once you
start to see that the grease is turning
into a yellowish tint of the color and
it's foaming you know that you're able
to hit it with the hot water pressure
washer
the temperature of the hot water
pressure washer allows the grease to
really soften up and it moves a lot
easier than trying to do with a cold
water pressure washer now that we have
flushed the entire ductwork back into
the kitchen we are able to apply a low
pressure high steam rinse of the kitchen
Hood so the opening to the ductwork in
the hood system starts behind the hood
filters the way we clean this is exactly
as the rest of the system we do not
neglect any areas of the duct this needs
to be degreased scraped and steam
cleaned
[Music]
foreign